this is a production of Cornell
University
okay thank you very much so the thank
you very much for introduction and the
I'd like to start my the topics at Panda
to minimize a technical problem I use a
PDF instead of a PowerPoint
so I have the five spirited that image
topics and the I've already introduced
but the I've been with the different
International Organization part-time
that's how I continue to work with the
international communities especially
with the cgl centers ginbank and also if
you
so uh my environment in the past was
already introduced and many people had
the retired or are still active and I
have the particular interaction with the
potato group in the past now the doctor
the water Dijon take care of potato
group
so in the past the I was working more
with the breeding aspect of the
so-called the utilization while the
potato genetic resources to introduce
its property like the disease and the
pesto resistances and the with the
working
uh the with potatoes and gradually I
shifted that incorporating the also
installation approach so I have about
the half of the own genetic resource
utilization half of the application over
the summer the genetic engineering at
the present activities so here I am the
many of you may know that that Scuba is
a nearby Tokyo and it is the one the
major science City so that we have the
local interactions for the technical and
scientific collaboration with the
different National and private
institutions
here are the I am talking about genetic
resources and that is there are many
textbooks at the state the phatogenetic
resources but principally I use a use of
time stated that the failed
International Authority Under the sum of
what quantity I have here sometimes you
may not finding glossary or the
vocabulary book in textbook that I
checked over the several Gene Bank book
of the plant Genetic Resource books like
a land race and accession so they are
used with this time of body use here to
talk this at the Caucasian
so prontogenetic resources how did we
recognize
um the talking about the plants are the
plant kingdom so starting from a single
cellular the photosynthetic the
microorganism too angiosperm you may
counter the over the 300 300 000 species
and roughly 80 000 species can be used
for humor in terms of chewing biting
spice and all the stability through the
crop
but how many all body these are the 80
000 species used so locally like the one
specific spot in Japan maybe we use 300
species year round and also another day
several hundreds of the harvesting but
probably the city people who don't use
the crops at the over plants at the
harvested from nature so very little
number oh but the species used in
proportion to available number at many
places like the our case in Japan and
they're talking about the how
those all body species that invested
already dedicated for research probably
less than 100 species have a high
intensity of our activities from
research to the production under the
markets so we have a lot of theater
potential also we are talking about a
lot of biodiversity laws and the species
loss under monoculture in agriculture
so one of the example of the past study
several decades that how cardiac one
species utilized in other places so
duragon fruits so this one originally
from Mexico
but the popularity went up in Southeast
Asia starting from Vietnam so the
Vietnam benefited a lot by the producing
this and exporting this club to the
overseas especially to some over
temperature zone countries
21st century by exploiting the samadi
species as the interest introducing into
the someplace you may have chance like
this
so in case of Mexico before the Vietnam
and the southeast Asia they popularized
this the dragon fruits was the Lazada
species uh but now the Mexico also the
ketchup to produce the language of
fruits so some of the external influence
also important for original Prosperity
those are species
uh stable crops so they hear the at the
corner you have a diversity of a
background and the origin of
nationalities so you may recognize that
the factors they are on this photo and
indeed
looking at the understanding of the
students at a different country
sometimes sometimes it's not a popular
like you see here per minute surgeon and
the quinoa so place to place they are
important but other places may not be
recognized very well
so introducing information materials to
one place to other also the buried for
promoting God utilization
indeed not only availability of
materials so knowledge is important this
was East African cases all but how local
people use of course not only available
species but also how to use always
important including a transitional
knowledge
and also
talking about the common the crop like a
banana but we have the in the global
market is a particularly one group of
banana Cavendish group but uh talk uh
looking at the uh those whole body
supposed to be origin of banana actually
origin banana not yet the Korea maybe in
Papua New York
or the Continental southeast Asia and
that this case is that in Myanmar local
banana varieties you see here the
diversity of bananas so the this is
contrast Global Market the principally
one group of banana but are looking at
the availability of a different banana
varieties there are a lot indeed
cancer Myanmar already this is the more
than the one decade ago research using
SSN marker on banana and comparing a
Myanmar Corrections with the global the
core correction available from Singapore
under the uh
extent of diversity of Myanmar banana is
wider equivalent to the international
Corrections so place to place the
looking at the availability materials
yet you may find the uniqueness and
which can be used under the adding up a
new varieties
so Mexico I have a lot of involvement
Mexico is a one particular country that
they have a lot of group Origins under
the they have Supply and I like avocado
uh the uh Mexico grow export it is
important but the principle you want to
varieties like has has major variety and
plant breeding also not a much of the
popular in Mexico but it was abroad to
Hawaii and uh Hawaii I made a lot of
avocado breeding so the movement of
materials are often important like here
you see tomato chili uh spicy the most
spicy chili is not in Mexico probably
maybe United States or the some part of
South Asia so the higher the capsizing
value
by the Asian countries
so the by introducing clubs sometimes
are they because they have their own Are
The Movement uh and the Improvement and
the change
so let me go a little bit on the
scientific need I have been working with
a Mexican the international gym bag and
a particularly research promotion and
the there are a lot of the local Club
species that do not have enough
background on the botany especially the
reproductive biology and cytogenetics
that are the even common crops uh uh
like the open Tia this one is a cactus
pear there is the produce series
deployed to hexaploid and maybe a not
quite clearly species identification
that are the quite a basic work still
needed for the sum of a species even in
Mexico so I pick up them as the interest
on finding out more the scientific
information in terms of body relative
biology
change a bit the subject a secondary
diverse also the unique so uh faziolence
study being
originated in the like a northern part
of South America Cabernet Colombia too
Miss America
and also Chile uh the in the this uh
your new continent and move to Africa
and that they have only diversity change
like you see the color of beans and also
the bell-shaped type of chiri and the
Maize are the obviously those are the
origin the Hindi makes go down to Miss
America and about Amaze moved to Asia
like this case is Myanmar maintain also
the changes by their use locally so the
moving under the utilization uh provide
also the unique and also the diversity
changes depends on how people use
and also secondary diversity is not a
second hand a case of potatoes a major
potato origin in the South America
Bolivia Peru likely but the talking
about the plant breeding the aspect so
the potato has the fungal disease
problem lead of light and a little
brighter major ladies and souls I think
came from Mexico Vietnam Mexican sauce
is an important for potato later
resistance and ingredients so praise to
praise are looking at the utilization
popular utilization that will help body
also the the genetic change
anyway looking over human history a lot
of groups are moved and they also
utilized the one place to other so I
don't lead over but there are examples
already I mentioned here
and also the crops supported
civilizations and you may look at in a
babylof or jakaharan books and also the
Japanese are the Scara in the past the
Casas
proposed a similar context on the how
prop supported the civilizations under
the also the spread over the war so this
one just the illustration for your
recordings if you are interested in
adding some of the opinion came out from
an account
uh moving to Jim Bank
Jim bank here is the backup over the
genetic resources and uh can be at The
Supply Center for the acid stock under
the globally maybe you count
1700 the gym banks at the international
national gym bags could they see the
stock Center or could be filled are the
three standard Center and also the you
make the incorporate some mobile
research Botanical Garden uh Cube
Botanical Garden in the uh United
Kingdom
so around the seven million accessor
accounting took uh like a CGR review
ipoit are they can maintained at the
auto uh after the dose gym bags so those
are fatally correction made but a
particularly major proportion uh on uh
like a seed of propagated species
under Jim Bank conservation there are
the the field of Correction into Gene
bank or the uh like our own Farm
materials into ginbank or exchange
between zimbank then the corrections are
being maintained and are evaluated under
characterized sometimes for the specific
purpose for supporting bleeding and the
information Supply and the user can be
here I have more the research oriented
user listed what are the several steps
that they need for gym bag so far to
conserve fat to correct and genetic
Integrity in terms of information
information accumulation and information
at the supply so the halfways are the
material aspect at the half is the
information are the management
and also in terms of Information
Management it's not only the database
but also some other active publication
like uh the same over uh somebody or
body under utilized species I have this
summer the case uh with the tools in
Bank collaboration with Myanmar under
Pakistan
under the users you've already seen like
a breeder or researcher and also the gym
bag function can can be excrete inside
like you see at the Norway uh swarovar
Global City Bar
this one is a long time and the
conservation Leica it may say frozen
Botanical Garden
The Other Extreme side is my recent
experience that the uh Myanmar Hazard
Equator the vandalism problem and a lot
of refugees out from country especially
to Thailand
they don't have a crop to grow so see
the supplied from the Thai Jin bank or
the in this case University
camp for uh let those people grow they
are the original traditional crops so
cases
principle you see central part the
correction conservation documentation
those are pathetic keypad for gym bag
under the gene bank I think I mentioned
that the international Gene bank I think
many of you Harvard exposure to CGR
centers they have the measure the
contributions International Gene bank
and also you see this bad Global City
Bar but this verbal case is a seed of
the bank not that the basically
propagated species Bank principle so the
gene Bank function different and
especially National Gene bank at the
capacity are the cavalries depends on
how they are supported by the local
government or local community but the
important part is that Gene Bank cannot
be Standalone even larger the
international gym bags need to have
collaboration so CGR Center cases
collaboration or to complement each
other
likewise the national museum
so the domestic system Gene Bank uh like
in United States you have the ngrb and
also the uh National plants are the uh
John prasm distance Information Network
and the archery my career started that
the stadium Bay nrsp6 potato gymbank
research and that I continued working
this one too little to lead over uh but
with many national Gene Bank I've worked
all a particularly collection and also
the Samo body variation are the
activities
challenge I would say there are many
especially now because of many
International laws and the domestic
requirement access and the benefit of
sharing ABS facilitation is a one nobody
key are the activities for many over the
national Gene bank and also the gene
Bank need to store their genetic
resources for long term so long-term
continuity in terms of
resources especially Financial aspect
and the stability in terms of over the
local security and also the locality the
safety
and this one is at the Myanmar field of
gym bag of rice and the they try to
rejuvenate seed but front side you see
the parties that you don't see the
plants don't grow so the gene Bank are
they often itself has a problem already
some whole body loss over materials it's
not about the management but that is
sometimes study because of property of
accession or correction it could happen
so always the Jing Bank also need to
make the complementing of their
collections
and also I mentioned that the
collaboration important and this case is
that the Mexican collaborate with the
North Americans and also the
particularly Central and American the
Caribbean Nations for intelligent Bank
collaborations
also I mentioned about the casida
aspects and the vegetatively propagated
species need to have alternative
approach maybe at least the stock
growing Peak
conservation is one of the area over
research are still needed especially the
current species they need to have a
specialized procedures it's not only
just a different side and Noah also
background cryobiology science I need to
back up how to make a effective body
conservation of the culture and species
like autonopical trees
and are talking about the stock you
maintained in the bank sometimes
you may wonder what is the genetic the
integrity and the genetic change so
mango the example so the mango is
actually and the vegetatively
propagating like by the choreographing
and the Myanmar case there are several
Major League varieties
that is name but within the name
actually genetically differences only
take place so the aspects is the feature
the plants or a standard representative
genotype of the land race or at all
additional variety I think we made that
is some old body local collection of a
field of standard look at the diversity
over land race and actually one two
landowner's name has aquatogenetic
variation you see here the selection
analysis you using Isis and markers so
jeanback also need to have a research on
fat people concept so otherwise the uh
you may have the incorrect direction of
a very Narrows are the storage over
diversity concept
and the other aspect of the Edition
right now ongoing on ginger blast this
one is a glucuminoid at the one nobody
medicality attribute are the commonly
used and we have the accessions of one
purokuma are the Armada which is a
regulative
turmeric and we look at the cool
Community content so depends on the the
correction or accession uh the quieter
the variation content and the spectrum
of a group node you see g89
0.675 under z23 hyphoon one almost
nothing phrase so depends on correction
the people claim that this species has a
cool communities but it is quite a
variant so by evaluating this there is
the basic information and the lead to
the initial phase of plantar leading by
selection
so the gene Bank needed research
capacity not only conservation
Expedition so I go five minutes on the
Expedition Expedition or the human body
finding over the new plants are easily
started from prehistoric but I enhanced
at the age of a discovery under the past
study several hundred years ago
colonization started and that is that
one also be
proximity to find out the use of
plantagenetic resources
and the Yeta 20th century because of the
large-scale the crop production uh the
plant Hunters I looked at the different
sessions or these species so actually
botanists are the Pronto hunters and you
see our names here in the past 300 years
under Lee Center the activities and
especially the 20th century U.S had a
lot of mission for collecting the crop
genetic resources like the flank media
maybe they picked up in the plant
breeding book in United States
and also in parallel I mentioned already
baby
they have a proposed proposing and the
importance of those origin over groups
association with the civilization
two example medicine how plants
contributed uh some of classic example
is the queening at the finding and it is
yet at the common malaria remedy and
also the Artemisia and also couple of
body species are the problem to be very
effective for cancer remedy like the
foreign
[Music]
although those are directly from plants
yet effective medicine USD cancer remedy
and obviously science support the
Chinese traditional medicine under
Europe so the uh although the finding
out a new medicine at the present at the
modern society but looking at the how
plants contributed uh it's a big
contribution
biomaterial so you may go over the
balance over the conversible energy and
the recyclable energy so plants can
provide a reproducible industry biomass
that is how they are contributing could
contribute more a lot of potentials
but talking about the genetic resources
and the human utilize yet that is there
are potential and more responsibility by
introducing informational materials from
one place to other but since early 1960s
there is
more and more coming up on National
sovereignty lights on natural resources
including the genetic resources so each
country has a more protectionism rather
than sharing genetic resources so it is
very difficult to get even four academic
research material from one country into
like a case in Japan uh so the anatova
procedures are still here in the bottom
so uh and also it could be provided the
boss the benefit and also the future
potentials
so saying so about uh present study
nationality ownership of the concern uh
Bank want to correct uh depends on the
Jim Bank commission under the use of the
requirement like a printer plant
breeders or industry jimberg go to
correction or exchange of material with
other Gene Bank what are the how to set
up the planning it is also associated
with a presenter the access possibility
by legalization and also uh particularly
covet but also the globalization already
instability in terms of the security and
the variable of the climate change those
also affect the whole expeditions
[Music]
talking about Expedition under the
also Fat Daddy you would have
information is also important here you
see Southeast Asian vegetable market
having a design
here you see eggplant and the letters
battery
looking at the fair they are originated
there are still the crops that would be
introduced from the tropical Zone to
other places temperatures zones so let's
show you photo at the last study slide
Saturday here that are the cucurobitasia
in case there are these three major the
origins
so the depends on crops are the phrase
to look at the difference and that also
each country has a different policy and
the regulations on access topics but
anyway the practice in the Expedition
the past few years it was very difficult
to go around because of covet but I
think these are animated study
especially going to Myanmar area under
the very difficult Mountain Zone and
sometimes complex Zone having a bombs
are the uncorrected so this one uh
lighter bottom is a sign of they have a
lot of body problems but anyway we
couldn't make it and uh find out the uh
something new like you see while the
banana which is a deployed I have the uh
biography and the likely a species of
Musa nuggets not consume and obviously
they can not only getting Expedition the
permission correction permission jump
rasmatics
material transfer agreement here you see
the plant quarantine certificates that
is another things that you need to
prepare so the a lot of paperwork
actually needed for Expedition or the
aspect so they those are the operational
points that I summarized and uh I hope
that you can leave you uh that the time
is limited but the important thing is
that it's not already done in the short
time planning interactions especially
long time interactions to make a part
ownership building and also they often
we go to rural area The Village
experience they have no prior experience
with experience with foreigners so we
are surrender so you have to have a
precaution over how to behave well uh
with the correction
foreign
I think it is a common deal the future
that are the Expedition Specialists
throughout the endangered The Entity
that we need to have those people having
a botany knowledge a crop knowledge and
the plant breeding knowledge and also
those of legal processes and the also
important part is we go from quite a
distant location where we have
difficulty so mental preparation is also
important quite the unexpected things
could happen
moving for one night so I didn't expect
so sometimes those are the academic
nature boundary problem May came up and
also place to place this one is a Kenya
and the I'm required to ask escort to
buy some of Rangers to going because of
several reasons maybe wild animal or
poachers under or the some over the
criminals so the place to place there is
local rule to follow under the pay
precaution
and often they can we go about the zone
so the Border Zone requirement we have
to follow so it's not only direct study
the Expedition permission but also
security permission sometimes needed to
clear out then finally I could reach to
the center you see the farming Community
between Thailand
so the yeti Expedition
uh we may learn a lot by looking at a
dose of bang the other shifting field
how to utilize that species
and also the there is Institute site
like a wild equalized study the habitat
back in my portal that they identify
those locations as the on-site at the
conservation site besides a gene Bank
activities
and the important part is a fact to use
and how to use so the looking at the
seasonal or the different of the time
and the different locations how
vegetables are used so this one is not
something actually research that how
visible are using Southeast Asia
so expenditure have a lot and yet the
not only Expedition by looking at the
information
you may introduce any groups these cases
from South Africa
and uh flowers today I don't discuss but
because there are also a lot of flower
genetic resources available that could
be future potential also even while the
grass here by applying the modern
science especially biotechnology uh this
one accumulates salt and the sort of the
tolerance can be studied and
Incorporated by
genetic engineering so the more the
potential by science help
so that's how I conclude the ways that
it is the last topics
that the Genetic Resource aspect of the
has increasing the property like the
insist National Sovereign
particularly because of General speaking
technology biotechnology availability
can change including informatics that's
how modern are the quora the changes
that it is very difficult on access
issues
and indeed a past study 30 years there
are a lot of discussion by diversity
especially genetic resources at a
different Enterprise other Global basis
under the
especially SVG contain a component of
biodiversity under change the world to
genetic resources
they have a quieter emphasis
and I have somebody already my God
experience participating in
International League conventional
negotiations especially conventional
biological diversity
cbd's mobile environment and also the
intellectual property coming with the
varieties and the patents so the WTO
coming up coming up so different
International reform are discuss about
the genetic resources and the data
complicated that how to use Genetic
Resource are newly available from other
countries so these signs are present for
um not too easy to access and are not
easy to use genetic resources okay newly
from the doors over the other countries
so that's how not only knowing the
parties are the botany under the genetic
resources legal aspects are also
negotiation capacity those are the facts
are also important that's how the I
propose are the a decade ago there is a
new type of specialist needed and indeed
that the specialist requires a more
legal capacity and this one what I have
done the five years ago to have fast
case with Mexico under the conventional
virus can diversity to mobilize the
Mexican the crop genetic resources this
one is a chayote so the I'm also the
learning those of experiences that are
fat to do with 21st century paradigm
so we can do a lot of study in
scientific term but we also need to look
at the legal aspects so the uh I've been
working with those of international
negotiation especially in the past
United Nations University then I came up
with the concept of biodipomacy that the
biotechnology biodiversity Genetic
Resource those are the key factors for
attentive first century it's not only
the science but also we have to look at
the diplomacy and the legal aspect to
utilize so that's how I propose and the
working by biodiver diplomacy concept
besides doing the biological research
so just a time and I drive to end and
this one is what I mentioned snake Goose
under the lady at the center is also
Corner graduate uh Madame Ambassador
over Indonesia
Japan and we evaluate the South East
Asian tropical vegetable radical
responsibility in Japan particularly
scuba so around us are already a
tropical vegetables we can Harvest even
October so unfortunately unfortunately
because of climate change we can do like
this
after temperature
okay thank you very much for the your
the time under the uh I think I'm open
to your comments and the question
thank you Dr Watanabe for your lovely
presentation today I would like to take
a question and the first question I hope
will come from a graduate student either
in the room or online
yes Lucia
I wanted to ask
about this morning
hi uh thank you for your talk I wanted
to ask you about uh conservating Poland
in the
um in the gene Banks and about the
location of the gene Banks related to
the species that they are collecting if
they should all be in the center of all
origin and what happens with the species
species that have been uh not paying
paid attention to
um
thanks
uh your question uh have a two
components right you ask about the
polling right
yes
so the uh I think it is limited because
the viability report and changes a
species species so like a solar species
you make a uh keep it for six months in
freezer but uh maybe at the graminia
like right spotting can be the one day
so the uh that one is at the area not
too much exported but usually are the
those over the embryo are the
case can be concerned
under the talking about under utilized
species so the it easily recommended by
different groups like one is cgir FAO
that is some other priority setting are
given but actually it's short-handed my
understanding on covering many blocks so
the it's not only international airport
but the local effort more important data
what to conserve in terms of their
traditions and also documenting the
information is that the way you have
asked me questions
yes yes perfect
hi I have a question
um so the United States where we are in
Japan where you are moving places that
have not traditionally been opposed to
biopiracy or we probably wouldn't call
it that
um but do you think there's any shift in
how the United States and Japan view
that
yes uh that's a good question
biopyracuse
International Energy old and uh it
sounds a very Sensational but the
commercial cases are the either
misappropriation of understanding of a
procedure or misunderstanding over how
to communicate in terms of the process
over the access topics under the uh it
is at the coming with two fairness uh in
terms of like environmental S6 Concepts
would have another session over the
environmental ethics but you talk about
the common sense of conservential to
others so the private informed the
content is important often it is missing
but also the uh the country of origin
often are the fields of the loss so
sense over the something so for me to
come to us at the undigested that the uh
and easiness expressed as the bio piracy
so the many cases actually they picked
up as a bipiracy either the short-handed
explanation under the side of each other
they acquire the genetic resources that
is at the very general but in my
understanding my understanding look
looking over Japanese case the most of
case like that
any other questions in the room
I'll just walk to you
and give you the microphone
right follow-up question from Lucia
what do you have to do if you want to
donate material do you can you have just
one plant or you need to have many of
them
so that is a good question uh actually
Jim bank has a specification that they
need to have the certain number of a
seat like 500 seeds or maybe at the 1000
series uh or the sum of information
should come with like the uh if you know
the best short of information here they
are from a GPS data or the donors uh
would be helpful but the bear hunt
usually because
difficulty to receive it so instead of
that there is a low calorie Casino
depository openly take place after the
many countries instead all by the full
functions but the local community a
correction prefecture or state
but sometimes they take care of that but
there is no systematic requirement or
specification indicated
my understanding
are there any questions from Geneva or
elsewhere online in the world
you can either unmute and ask the
question or you can put in a chat and I
can read it for you
yeah indeed that the Geneva is a good
place to visit other representation or
by Jim Bank activities pgr unit of IRS
are there under the it's the quite
active my understanding
very active so I have a question for you
so you've worked in a few different
countries are there any countries in
particular
who do not have a gene bank and that you
think are at risk for not having a gene
Bank
many countries don't have a systematic
gym Bank function and uh they have this
community or a national program so
indeed that this small country with a
small budget a lack of human resources
or from the the heart problem even the
country here they have the national
agriculture system and the so-called
Gene Bank are they looking at entities
they have uh just a concept of the
Botanical stuff not as a genetic
resources that means
reproduce uh so
I would say maybe at the uh quite a
large proportion of so-called Nations
maybe you can counter 200 Nations more
than half would have a problem or but
their capacity in terms of how to
conserve the genetic resources
great thank you for that answer
all right so rumors at the end of our
time are in your last minute or two
minute questions from the room or even
online
if not let's thank this speaker one more
time
thank you very much
so thank you so much because I realize
it's after 2 A.M there and you're
probably pretty tired now so thank you
and I think you have more time to talk
with people right or yes
right right okay good and I think uh
there was a question from Lee cast for
your email and Lee you can see the email
in the the last slide
okay yes now the I communicate
communicated in the past with Lee
um
topics I remember you
so so that grows at this
yes I will close it okay thank you
thank you and uh I hope I see you in
future
hopefully soon yes
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu